the skill set of content in Social
matters a lot more than if you're a
travel blogger there's a million travel
bloggers that don't get any views
attention is the number one
asset it doesn't matter if you're in Sri
Lanka Japan or Manhattan if you want to
reach people you need to make sure you
know what time to post what the first
three seconds of the video look like
what the thumbnail looks like how
LinkedIn Works different than YouTube
you have to understand the distribution
and the content that works in it and
then more importantly the slang the
wording the copywriting the skill set of
content in Social matters a lot more
than if you're a travel blogger there's
a million travel bloggers that don't get
any views how well do you know your
content of all the things you've learned
self-defense all this firearm training
and then how good are you at the craft
of putting out the videos the pictures
and the written words on these 10 social
media platforms that dictate Society